salut les heures de pool tu vois il se
réveille un matin il y a 50 poules qui
meurent il devient fou qu'est-ce qu'il
fait va voir le rabbin d'à côté du Rabbi
j'ai un problème je me suis réveillé le
matin il y a 50 poules qui sont morts
comment je peux faire et du coup ce que
tu fais va voir tes poules ce soir
raconte-leur une histoire comme ça ils
vont dormir et personne va mourir il dit
d'accord il va il le raconte une
histoire
il était une fois un prince une
princesse maman il se réveille le matin
sans poule qui meurent
regardez j'ai fait ça dis-moi c'est ce
que c'est chantez-lui du Jean-Jacques
Goldman chanter le Jean-Jacques Goldman
le soir ça va leur faire du bien ils
vont dormir l'autre il arrive elle a
fait un bébé tout
il part en concert de Jean-Jacques
Goldman il se réveille le matin 200
poules qui meurent
il va voir il dit ravi écoutez vous
m'avez donné plusieurs solutions mais ça
marche pas est-ce que vous avez d'autres
solutions
j'en ai mais est-ce que toi tu as assez
de poule
[Applaudissements]